vor drei wochen war die eskalation der
krise noch nicht spürbar zur tieres
liberopoulos macht sich wie jeden morgen
auf den weg um an mehr wildpflanzen
zusammen alle paar meter zeigt mir der
fußhaut etwas genießbares das ist der
vorläufer von knoblauch willst du
probieren
der wilde knoblauch ist erstaunlich
würzig und hinterlässt dennoch keinen
üblen nachgeschmack
wir folgen den spuren von sotirios ahnen
sie kamen als normal nach messina an der
westküste des peloponnes und ernährten
sich von dem was das meer und die berge
hergab
heute ist das lokale nahrung sammeln ein
trend das wissen aber ist jahrtausende
alt sotiris hat von einheimischen
gelernt und sich mit büchern kundig
gemacht
das ist greta muss es ist eine sehr
schöne pflanze weil sie während des
sommers wächst ohne wasser kreta muss
lebt hauptsächlich von der
luftfeuchtigkeit
stell dir vor wie stark diese pflanze
ist sie wächst auf einem felsen und sie
ist den felsen sogar ein bisschen auf
die wildpflanzen sind überhaupt starke
pflanzen
sie brauchen keine menschen um zu
überleben sie sind widerstandsfähig und
deshalb auch so gesund all das fremde zu
probieren gibt mir ein mulmiges gefühl
doch sotiris hat schon über 200 pflanzen
erforscht und nimmt rücksicht auf mich
diese pflanze rest admira
sie ist sehr salzig wir essen sie
normalerweise gekocht
wir probieren sie hier aber leider nicht
weil es so brutal ist für deinen wagen
hatte sie noch nie gegessen hast würdest
du dich unwohl fühlen
der 34-jährige so tieres ist nicht nur
sammler von raren pflanzen
er ist auch ein cleverer geschäftsmann
trotz schon damals schwierigen zeiten
gründete er vor fünf jahren seine firma
die mittlerweile beschäftigt er sechs
festangestellte und 40 freelancer ein
wichtiger teil meines business ist es
familien von hier zu beschäftigen
viele arme familien leben von dem was
ich mache ich mag es hier in der gegend
etwas bewirken zu können
sotiris bringt mit seiner arbeit so sagt
er selbst ein wenig wohlstand auf dem
peloponnes der salzige meeresspiegel
etwa und der würzige thymian vom
meeresufer sind angesagt in der
spitzengastronomie besonders begehrt die
stachelige wegwarte er sagt sehr
schwierig sie zu erhalten
wenn du sie berührt merkst du warum das
tut ist voller stacheln ist man nun das
blatt es ist ziemlich bitter das ist die
bitterste wildpflanze dies gibt und du
gibst sie mir zu essen was bitte ist
sehr wichtig weil viele menschen zu viel
zu viel salz essen können sie das bitte
nicht mehr akzeptieren
aber die dinge sind die gesündesten
sortiere es braucht stunden lang um die
kleinen blätter zwischen den stacheln
hervor zu glauben
dafür verkaufte sie für satte 35 euro
pro kilo
dass er weiß wie man trotz
wirtschaftskrise ein business in schwung
bringt kommt nicht von ungefähr
er studierte ökonomie in athen und
logistik in london
dann schmiss er die karriere hin wollte
lieber an die sonne und ins meer
er verzichtete auf luxus lebte mit
seinen kumpels monatelang unter einem
baum
er wurde veganer lernte die wildpflanzen
kennen baute gemüse an
dann ein mutiger schritt er klopfte mit
seinen exklusiven wildpflanzen bei den
besten restaurants in paris an und
insistierte so lange bis in die spitzen
köche erhöhten danach konnte er die
gehobene gastronomie in paris london und
athen beliefern
der export seiner exquisiten funde am
meer macht aber nur einen kleinen teil
seines geschäftes aus stolz zeigt mir so
tieres dass er dieselben pflanzen auch
auf seinen feldern kultiviert gemeinsam
mit anderen gemüsesorten ohne pestizide
diese günstigeren pflanzen sind bei
qualitätsbewussten restaurants ebenfalls
begehrt noch läuft das business privat
ist so tieres selbstversorger er kann
seine familie fast ausschließlich von
dem ernähren was er selber findet und
züchtet selbst seine tochter sammelt und
ist was die natur hergibt
selbstversorgung das könnte in
griechenland schon bald existenziell
werden jetzt mitte juni ist sortiere es
noch zuversichtlich natürlich betrifft
uns die krise es ist nicht gut wenn die
leute kein geld haben aber wir wollen
arbeiten wir wollen nicht negativ denken
ich will arbeiten und ich glaube wir
können erfolgreich sein
krise hin oder her jetzt genießen wir
erst einmal die früchte unserer heutigen
sammle arbeit
gekocht und mit olivenöl und zitrone
verfeinert sind die wildpflanzen
besonders lecker so lässt es sich in
griechenland leben
doch drei wochen später ist alles anders
sotiris einkommen ist um 70 prozent
zurückgegangen
die restaurants stehen leer seine
frischprodukte verderben so tieres ist
gestresst hat die hoffnung aber nicht
verloren
für mich ist die wahrscheinlichste folge
unserer politik dass die meisten firmen
griechenland verlassen werden und die
menschen werden ärmer werden
also werden weniger leute auswärts essen
noch weniger werden sich gute essens
qualität leisten können wir werden unser
geschäftsmodell überdenken
wir werden uns auf den export
konzentrieren weil wir glauben dass es
auf dem tschechischen markt in den
nächsten fünf jahren sehr schwierig sein
wird
in zukunft werden gemäss also nach paris
oder london reisen müssen um
wildpflanzen von so tieres zu kosten